let's go the first time that we get to
see Wiley and Simone together will
always be special it's the first scene
that Betty and I had it was really the
first time sweet angel Jake McDormand
and I realized oh this is the job we've
been waiting for
I'm Betty Gilpin I'm Damon Lindelof I'm
Tara Hernandez hi I'm Jay McDormand we
are sharing some of our favorite moments
from peacock's new original series Mrs
Davis the hatch scene really stands out
in the pilot hidden access tactical
camouflage Hideout those are all the
same word Wiley definitely thinks that
he's the lead character of his own uh
action movie Simone kind of rips that
theory to pieces and pokes holes in it
um and reduces him to you know a
bickering child as an ex-girlfriend can
do what is that on your face
what my stash I mean can you even eat
with that God's sake so can you just
fine worried about crying look I've
never worked with Betty before we didn't
even do a chemistry read I think we
clicked really fast they had wired a
little electric light for us to play
with to turning the light on turning the
light off that was actually a bit that
was from my audition tape on the first
day when we got to set oh and our
director was like you know we actually
had the electrical department wire a
light bulb and in the middle of the
scene so that was fun because it already
felt like this collaborative creative
supportive environment where Betty and I
could start playing with props that you
know were on set they cross-covered that
scene which means they had two cameras
rolling simultaneously just so that we
could talk over each other and play
around see I jumped to that donut that
was pretty cool right what no we
realized how much fun we were gonna have
acting together and that we would get to
do it for seven months
um and we wanted to keep doing that
scene over and over again and we were
both really sad when they told us that
we were done Lizzy
I'm sorry
my name is Simone
my favorite scene is the opening of
episode two ladies and gentlemen we get
to meet young Lizzy we find this young
girl at a magic show and we realized
that she's not just an audience member
but a shill which is sort of a plant in
the audience and that The Magicians on
stage are actually her parents my Brave
volunteer's name is
name Lizzy Lizzy making this reveal in a
short period of time so that we're not
away from Betty Gilpin Simone for too
long sort of seven minutes convey a
childhood which ultimately culminates in
her getting a crossbow to to the liver
which again is also horrific I mean yeah
and it hurts
in sort of the horror of that moment she
meets young Wiley and sort of they're me
cute as two young kids uh in the
hospital on Halloween night was just a
particular Joy I like your costume
Marley
it's actually not a costume
so cool
I've always wanted to meet a real cowboy
that's so weird
I've always wanted to meet a real wizard
on the writing side we we were able to
you know give our director Owen Harris
you know a real nice sort of tapestry of
this young girl's life and then you know
he did what he does so well and you got
amazing performances specifically from
you know Stella and Kaden the young the
young actors who betrayed Lizzie and
Wiley so for all the reasons I'm going
to say the top of episode two and then I
guess it's your lucky day
foreign